les bergeron merci beaucoup d'être là
merci de vous être prêté au jeu on va
donc parcourir cette décennie en ordre
chronologique évidemment on commence
2010 on est clairement dans la foulée de
la crise financière
on sort de ce qu'on a appelé la grande
récession donc 2008 et crise financière
suivie d'une crise économique
essentiellement donc je la portais
peut-être une attention particulière à
la réaction des gouvernements et à la
façon dont certains gouvernements ont
voulu encadrer le secteur financier en
se disant essentiellement on ne veut
plus de ce type de crise larmes
aux états unis on est mis en place ça a
été mise en place en 2010 la loi
dodd-frank est une loi qui rentre pas
dans les détails mais qui encadre le
secteur financier et qui est cet exemple
ne permet plus aux institutions
financières de s'endetter autant donc on
ne souhaite plus tomber dans cette
spirale d'endettement qui omni disons le
la crise financière de 2008 et à la
crise économique donc mise en place de
certains garde-fous certains diront que
c'était pas assez que c'est une loi de
dons de compromis oui mais
essentiellement le décider des droitiers
pas parfait et ça sera modifiée par le
bond dans les années futures mais ça
c'est un autre dossier
il s'est peut-être un peu dans la foule
il s'en passe à 2011 les occupants socio
économique parce que lorsqu'on parle
d'une crise économique on parle
évidemment d'une crise sociale dans une
moindre mesure est tout même les gens
ont dû réagir à cette crise yeux des
mouvements de mobilisation qu'on le
constater à plusieurs endroits sur la
planète aux états unis à partir de
l'automne 2011 c'est réellement un
mouvement de dizaines de milliers de
personnes des habitants dénoncent les
inégalités l'inéquité également au sein
même de la population américaine
il y a nous sommes les 99% dès qu'ils se
mobilisent un dernier coup d'oeil 1% de
la population qui va chercher
disons le le pactole sur le plan
économique et donc des mouvements aux
états unis mais je voulais également
soumis que tout serait dans une dans une
mouvance globale mondiale parce que
rappelez vous il ya les indignés en
espagne il ya également des mouvements
sociaux en irlande
tu galles bref c'est un peu partout
parliez de l'europe 2011 la saga la
crise de la dette en grèce qu'on
n'aurait plus de mentions 2008 1 mais
avec la crise financière mais
essentiellement c'est une aube redire
c'est le symbole la grèce est devenue le
symbole en quelque sorte de l'impact de
la crise économique et de la crise
financière
c'est devenu une crise qui est un choix
politique au sein même de l'union
européenne également une crise
structurelle au sein de l'union
européenne c'est à dire qu'elles sont
des instants ce qu'on peut voir de
quelle façon on peut apporter de l'aide
à un pays
de quelle façon également doit le faire
crise politique ça mené au pouvoir un
parti d'extrême gauche
quelques années plus tard écrit sociale
encore une fois claire taux de chômage
dépasse les 25%
l'endettement de la grèce c'est un
certain moment là autour de 175% très
long steve remettre on en parle encore
d'ailleurs 2013
on revient au pays fermeture des hells
décision d'entreprise symptomatique des
difficultés dans le secteur absolument
dans ce secteur disons le c'est
extrêmement difficile on fait face dans
le commerce de détail à deux phénomènes
deux effets qu'on appelle entre autres
choses les faits ou en maths ont donc
cessé mes gags grandes surfaces qui sont
des méga magasins généraux
essentiellement donc ça sert un premier
aspect on a dû jongler avec cette
réalité ou pour des années 80 90 mais on
sait l'impact que mené entre autres
choses à la fermeture deux élèves mais
également les faits amazon qui se fait
sentir et lorsqu'on parle de fermat zone
on parle de quoi
c'est pas uniquement l'entreprise amazon
a en tout cas merci c'est tout le
commerce en ligne
users hilton avant
zeller a été entre les locaux ont été
achetés entre autres choses par walmart
target que fini par quitter assez
percuté à son tour donc disons que c'est
leur est devenu où on pourrait le
présenter comme un symbole de ce qui se
produit dans le commerce le premier dit
exactement et tout autour de petites
barrières ou six qui ont disparu par la
suite on passe à 2014 période
douloureuse surtout dans l'ouest chute
du prix du pétrole chute du prix du
pétrole
il faut se remettre en contexte monde
juillet 2014 l'arabie saoudite certains
pays de l'est qui sont producteurs de
pétrole qui sont membres de l'opep et
d'essayer de produire davantage de
pétrole donc l'offre augmente sur les
marchés pétroliers
c'est un impact direct sur les cours du
pétrole qui chute avec l'objectif dé
gringue l'objectif disons le était de
freiner la croissance des producteurs de
pétrole non conventionnel donc par non
conventionnel on parle du pétrole de
schiste aux états unis entre autres
choses le pétrole issu des sables
bitumineux on pourrait dire également
les régions difficiles d'accès
l'arctique
à titre d'exemple donc on réagit c'est
un impact et son impact est
inévitablement au canada et sur les
employés sur la devise les effets ont
été très très longue il ya peut-être un
petit lien puisqu'on parle de pétrole et
carburant diesel guèye 2015 volkswagen
ça a été le début d'une longue saga
douloureux et ç'a frappé fort rappelez
vous le matin lorsque l'annoncé sortie
de quelle façon ça a réagi s'élançant de
l'industrie automobile qui est affecté
je rappelle les faits on parle de diesel
gates me préparer au départ de scandales
volkswagen volkswagen qui s'est
organisée entre 2009 et 2015 pour ont
faussé les données en lien avec les
émissions polluantes les émissions de
gaz polluants
on saigne enquêter sur l'ensemble de
l'industrie automobile
on a découvert que plusieurs marques qui
appartenait à qui appartient toujours à
volkswagen
huet d'utiliser une stratégie similaire
tricheurs il dira on parle de fraude
audi c'était que pour audi s'était coupé
porsche entre autres choses
mais d'autres entreprises qui faussait
les données avec d'autres stratégies je
l'appelle mitsubishi entre autres choses
oui et ce scandale a coûté jusqu'à
maintenant cinq ingrédients de gras et
s'est pas terminée 2016
abbas à sa marque l'année du point de
vue économique politique sociale
l'élection d'un autre
j'hésitais en vous parlez de pokémon
godon on réellement parler à l'été 2016
mais disons que c'est un autre
personnage qui attire l'attention parce
que si c'est d'un autre homme qui arrive
vous savez en économie on parle de black
soins dans des fois de deux cygnes noirs
comme l'oiseau pour désigner c'est ces
événements qui change la donne
des événements imprévus l'élection de
deux mâles trompe et certainement
l'exemple du black sont par excellence
et dès son élection
on sent que ça va changer la donne par
le ton avec ses tweets ces fameux tweet
il s'attaque à ses propres entreprises
quand je dis ses propres entreprises
présenteront les américains entre autres
choses du secteur de l'automobile
s'attaque à des pays alliés
le canada l'europe entre autres choses
et la lada ya un avant et un après
donald trump on est dans cette terre
disons deux confrontations commercial de
prédilection de donneurs on le voit
encore la signature glacé home le
conflit avec la chine on en sent encore
les effets très marqué 2010 est chaud
qu'au québec
lombardi vent la cseries oui et fait un
beau rêve
qui commencée en 2008 rappelez vous on a
annoncé ce programme de ces series donc
un avion qui un programme qui permettait
de mettre en place des de construire des
appareils plus efficaces sur le plan de
l'énergie de la consommation de
l'énergie mais il ya deux problèmes
majeurs dans tous deux aussi
premièrement les retards ça a permis aux
concurrents directs de bombardier dans
ce créneau donc airbus et boeing de
réagir de réadapter de construire
différemment certains appareils comme
autorisé entre autres choses et le
carnet de commandes sont là on n'a
jamais réussi donc bombardier à remplir
un carnet de commandes et le bon on vend
là c'est series à airbus il à 220
aujourd'hui qui commence à décoller
commence à décoller il on le hait
gouvernementale du gouvernement du
québec pour une somme astronomique faut
le rappeler 2018 et ça facebook ont
marqué l'événement avec le scandale
cambridge analytique mais c'est aussi
une décennie facebook fille c'est une
décennie facebook j'appelle cambridge
analytique l'os est une société qui
analyse les données qui collectent les
données dans ce que si l'entreprise a
été impliqué dans la campagne électorale
de donald trump en 2016 c'est ce qu'on
apprend en 2018 c'est qu'on a utilisé
environ dont les données personnelles
sans consentement des utilisateurs
facebook d'environ 87 millions
d'utilisateurs facebook est là c'est
l'envers de la médaille de ces géants du
numérique en quelque sorte qui qui fait
son apparition au smac questionner non
seulement facebook mais l'ensemble de
ces de ces géants du numérique quant à
l'utilisation des données des données
personnelles
l'autre chose c'est le cas pour google
celle que pour à pau également 2018 je
rappelle lorsqu'on parle de gaffe à
google google apps on va dépasser les
1000 milles
hier de dollars en capitalisation
boursière encore de ces géants à partir
de ce moment là de façon quotidien oui
et là vous parlez de données
personnelles sera en lien avec 2019
on a choisi des jardins la crise mais
entreprise privée qui est la plus
importante ici au québec donc
inévitablement ça a eu un impact
bon là prenait dans les dernières
semaines ces 4 million deux cent mille
victimes de ce vol de données on n'est
pas assez 1re en quelques semaines de 3
millions environ peu moins de 3 millions
à 4 millions 200 mille ajouté détenteurs
de cartes de crédit a continué continue
de grimper
simplement rapplique c'est une remise en
question de l'utilisation des données
personnelles par les institutions
financières également pas uniquement des
jardins penser à bmo dans une moindre
mesure qui a connu des moments
difficiles et qui est devenu explique ce
qu'est devenu l'exemple à ne pas suivre
d'intérieur gestion de tricks desjardins
tout le monde dirait tout même bien
réagi en étant proactif et en étant
transparent dans ce dossier mais ce
n'est pas tout
non c'est clairement pas terminée c'est
des dossiers donc on va continuer de
suivre inévitablement dans la prochaine
décennie sera celle du père connectivité
défis environnementaux on se donne
rendez-vous en disant merci beaucoup
d'avoir fait ça pour sûr mois avant